The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu
WILLIAM GREEN: All
right, so today we're
going to keep on
working on stochastic.
And I guess maybe we start--
if you guys have questions
from the homework set,
since I'm sure you're thinking
about that a lot right now.
Are there any questions?
Should I take this to mean
that you have it completely
under control?
That's good.
All right-- so since we
have Monte Carlo integration
metropolis totally
under control,
let's talk about time dependent
probability distributions.
So in many situations,
we'd like to predict
what's going to happen
in an experiment.
And the fundamental
equations of that experiment
are time dependent, so we have
different things happening
at different times.
And so we really
want to know what
d dt of the probability
of some observable--
this is going to
equal something.
Let me fix the lights.
All right, so we want
some equation like this.
And then when you actually
made your measurement,
you'd be sampling from P.
So probability of
the observables--
and so if you made
the measurement,
you'd have a certain probability
that you observe something.
And you made a
different measurement,
you'd have same probability
if you made the measurement
at this time.
So this is going to be
probability of the observable
depending on the time.
And you made the measurements
at different times.
So let's conceptually
think about this.
Suppose we had a box.
And it had a uranium atom
in it that's radioactive.
And it can decay.
So we look in the box.
And at time zero,
I look in there.
And there's the uranium
atom sitting there nicely.
And I go away for a while.
They come back.
And I open the box.
And I look again later.
And there's some probability
that the uranium atom is still
there.
And there's some
probability that it
fissioned during the time
and it's gone, right?
OK so there must be
some kind of equation
like this, how the probability
that the uranium atom
is still there in the box.
Right, is this OK--
yeah?
So just for that case, what
do we think the probability--
how does that probably behave--
any ideas?
So uranium has a half-life
or something, right?
You guys heard
this before, right?
So let's just try to think
of how this should scale.
Whatever it is, it probably
should have something
to do with a time constant for
how fast uranium decays, yeah?
You guys are looking at
me, like, so blankly.
This is not that hard.
It's just one uranium atom.
It's OK.
All right, so let's just
write a plausible equation.
Maybe it's dP dt, where
this is the probability
that the uranium is in the box.
This might be the
probability divided by two.
Something like that--
would that be--
all right, I guess we need
a negative sign maybe.
So then the probability--
the solution to this
would be that the probability
that uranium is still there
is going to be equal to
some initial probability e
to the negative time over tau.
Does that look right?
Does this look very reasonable?
You might have seen
this before, yeah?
Maybe you didn't think
of it probability.
Maybe you thought about it as
number of uraniums in the box.
If I had written it as
the number of uraniums
is equal to the original
number of uraniums e
to the negative t
over tau, you guys
would have believed
that right away, right?
OK, so I guess maybe this is
highlighting a issue here,
is that we use a
macroscopic thinking.
We're used to thinking of
things as continuum, right?
But if I only have one uranium
there, it's either there
or it's not there.
It's 1 or 0.
So the problem with
this equation--
if you compute this, it
computes irrational numbers,
fractional numbers as
the number of uraniums.
But of course, the
number of uraniums,
it's just either--
it's integers, right?
There's one uranium atom, or
there's two, or there's three.
So this equation is
not right, right?
So this is incorrect.
So that was what you learned
in high school, right--
that equation?
But that's not right.
So this is really the correct
equation, that the probability,
that you have some number of
uraniums that does something.
You know-- well this works
for one atom, anyway.
So that's the equation for one.
So this is probability
I have one uranium.
It's the initial
probability that there's
one uranium in a box,
which is basically--
my case would be one.
I know I put one in there.
And then it just decays.
The probability decays.
But it doesn't mean
uranium decays.
So it means when I do-- if
I do the experiment once,
and here I have the uranium--
the probability of the uranium
is a simple exponential decay--
time.
I know I had a
uranium atom there
when I first put it there.
And at later times
it's gone away,
right? 'Cause at
longer and longer times
it's more and more likely
it would have fissioned.
They
Now if I actually do this.
And make a-- buy
a million boxes.
And put a million
uranium atoms-- one
in each one to start with.
And then I just keep
coming back once
in a while and
checking, what I'll see,
is that initially I had--
here's the number of uraniums.
Initially I had a
million uranium atoms.
And for some time period
I still had a million.
And then something
happened and one of them
went away, because one of the
fissioned, turned into lead--
or whatever they turn into.
All right, and so now I had
a million minus one uraniums.
They live for a while.
And then maybe
another one went away.
And then this time,
another went away.
And that time it lasted longer--
right?
This is what you really
expect to observe.
Is this OK?
And so this is sampling from
the probability distribution
that you would use.
Does that make sense?
So I'm sampling a million times,
so I have a million boxes.
This is the probability
distribution for one box.
And so I'm able to
figure this out.
Is this OK?
All right, so we'd like to
write equations like this
for more complicated systems.
But you'll still going to
have the same confusion,
that the probability is going
to be continuous variable.
And it's going to
behave in ways that
seem perfectly sensible to you.
But then every time
you do the experiment,
different things
will happen in time.
Because you have something at
the time-varying probability,
and each time you sample from
the probability distribution--
every time you do
the experiment,
it's like a particular
instance of sampling
from that probability
distribution.
And you might get that there
is 87 uranium atoms left.
And you might get
that there's 93.
And it's not because of
your measurement error.
It's because the intrinsic
system has its own randomness
to it, right?
You know, you look
at one uranium atom--
some uranium atoms live
for a million years.
And some uranium atoms might
decay in the next second,
right?
And you have no idea when
they're going to decay.
All you know is statistically,
on the average, uraniums decay
with a certain half-life,
which is pretty long, right?
All right, is this
totally obvious?
I can't figure it out.
Is this, like, totally
obvious, or totally confusing?
It's very funny-- with your
eyes and your expressions,
totally obvious and
totally confusing has
the same blank expression.
Can someone ask a question.
Maybe that would
help us to have a--
this is OK?
All right, this is the OK.
AUDIENCE: It's OK.
WILLIAM GREEN: This is OK.
All right, so it's
totally obvious--
good, hard to tell sometimes.
All right, so Joe Scott wrote
some brilliant notes trying
to explain how do this
for chemical kinetics, OK?
So you should
definitely read them.
They're in the-- posted
under the materials,
general section--
Stochastic Chemical Kinetics--
nice 20 page long thing,
something like that.
It's definitely
worthwhile to read it.
He was very nice at
writing very clear notes.
So I'll try to explain
his notes inexpertly,
in a short period of time.
I strongly recommend
you read them.
So the idea is that the
chemical kinetic equations
you guys have all used
are also incorrect,
right-- just like
this is incorrect.
Because this is assuming
that something that's
really a discrete variable
is a continuous variable.
And we do this all
the time, right?
We know that material
is made of atoms.
And so when you measure our
mass in a certain volume,
there only can be
certain discrete values.
But we always ignore that.
And we always treat is a
continuous variable, right?
So you have some flow--
some amount of liquid--
and you have some
amount of mass.
And it could be any number.
And we treat dm dt, or
things like dm dx, d rho dx--
we write those down
as if everything is
perfectly continuous variables.
And that's because that in
a lot of systems we have,
we have so many atoms--
and we can't measure
that well anyway--
that we couldn't tell if we
were missing one or two atoms.
Whether we end up with an extra
half an atom in our equations
or not makes no difference,
because we're not that precise,
right?
So we don't worry about it.
So we use contiuum
equations everywhere and--
but in many cases, what
we really should be using
are continuous equations
for probabilities.
And then as going to show you
how you do it for chemical
kinetics in a minute.
I'd say that this is super
fundamental, actually.
So quantum mechanics
says that everything
is wave functions,
which is actually
like the square root of
a probability density.
And the real equations are
really probability densities.
And so that's the real
fundamental equations.
Really, everything
is probabilities.
And when you make an
experiment, you're
just sampling from
the probability.
And all our continuum equations
are like approximations.
They're only valid in, like,
the large number of atoms limit,
OK?
I know this takes maybe
a change of thought,
because you're so used to
those continuum equations
you start to believe
they're really true, right?
You've probably used them a lot.
And you start to feel like
you love those equations.
They're your favorite equations.
You know, you have a
relationship with them.
Some of them you might
hate, some you love.
But at least, you have a
strong connection with them.
And you just find out
that actually they're
not even related to
the real equations.
The real equations are
actually something different.
This can be very
annoying, but it's true.
And when you get to smaller
and smaller systems that
have fewer and fewer
molecules in them,
then you get more and
more sensitive to the fact
that the regular
equations are incorrect.
And this comes up a
lot in small systems.
So many of you probably
will do research
that has to do with biology.
In biology there's cells.
Inside cells there's
subcellular structures.
Inside those
subcellular structures,
there's not very many molecules.
And so you often are at the
limit where you have, like,
one molecule of a certain
type inside this mitochondria,
or something.
And that's it.
And so you wouldn't expect the
continuum equations to work.
And in fact there's
a big field--
many people at
research do in here--
called single
molecule spectroscopy,
where you can measure the
motion of one DNA molecule
or something like that.
And so you really see
the individual molecules,
and the effects of the
individuality of the molecules.
And this is not only
true in biology.
For a long time--
there's a field
called emulsion polymerization.
You guys ever hear of this?
So like, all the
paint on the walls
here is made by that
process, where they
polymerize methyl methacrylate.
They want to make the
little beads of polymers
all have a small
dispersion as possible,
to make all the
molecules the same.
So what they do is they make
a colloidal suspension--
I'm going to draw
a little picture.
So they have the reactor.
They make little bubbles
of the monomer that
are suspended in some solid.
And inside each
of these bubbles--
because the way they
make them, they're
all about the same size.
So they all have
a lot of bubbles,
all about the same size.
And then they polymerize.
And they polymerize
each of them.
And they polymerize.
And basically, all the
material that's there
polymerizes into one molecule.
Now how do they
make that happen--
is that they introduce,
say, a free radical.
And one free radical gets
into one of these bubbles.
And it can polymerize
the whole thing,
because the reactions
are a radical plus
monomer goes to a polymer--
bigger polymer, right?
So polymer radical
size n goes to polymer
radical size n plus 1.
That's the
polymerization reaction.
Now normally, if you
did this in the bulk,
there would be a
lot of radicals.
And some of these guys
would react with each other.
And the radical will be gone,
because the two radicals would
react, make a new chemical bond,
and this process would stop.
And so this gives a big
dispersion in the size
of the polymer chains you get.
So to beat this, they do
emulsion polymerization.
And they make that number
of radicals so small
that statistically, at any
time, any of these droplets
either has zero or
one of radicals in it.
And there's not--
during the time
it does the polymerization,
there's not enough time
for a second radical to come in.
So it's only got one
radical, so that one radical
is going to eat up
every single monomer
molecule in the whole thing.
And so it's going take
a giant polymer, that's
a whole size of the emulsion.
If you made the drops too big,
you get two radicals in there.
And you get some
of this happening.
And then you get a dispersion.
So this is emulsion
polymerization.
All right, so cells have
small little volumes.
Colloids and emulsions
have small little volumes.
They all have-- that the--
some of the molecules-- the
important molecules are so--
have such low concentrations--
the volumes are so small,
that the concentration times
the volume is less than 1,
or about 1.
So that's for like-- you know,
your copies of DNA in you,
in your cells.
It's the same kind of thing
for radicals-- free radicals
in a polymerization system.
And similar things could
happen with, like, explosions--
different kinds of
rare events, that you
might have a very small
number of some really
important molecule.
And then whether or
not you have one or not
is really important, OK.
All right, so we want to
model those kinds of systems,
we have to worry
about the graininess.
So we want to write down
what the equation is dP dt.
So first you've got to
think, well what is P?
Let's do a case where I have
the reaction of A plus B
goes to C, OK?
Suppose this is the
only reaction that
can happen in our system.
The only molecules we
have in our system are
A's, B's, and C's.
And so our probability
distribution--
our probability
that we want to know
is how many A's, how
many B's, how many C's do
we have in our system, OK?
So that's the probability
we're interested to know.
We could have 5 A's,
2 B's, and 0 C's.
We could have 3 A's, 7 B's,
11 C's-- who knows, right--
different numbers like that.
If it gets out to be 10 to
the 23, then there's no point.
You don't have to do
this, because you can just
go back your continuum
equations, right?
But if you have 5, or
3, or 2, or 1, or 0,
then you really need to
worry about the graininess.
So you want to write
down an equation.
So here's a probability
of n A n B n C.
And it's going to equal to
reactions which consume--
if I'm in this state
that has a certain number
A's, B's, and C's,
and I can react away,
so I only have reactions--
for example, I'm in this state.
An d plus B could
react with each other,
and will react away.
So I'll have some reaction.
I'm going to write
a k, but we'll
come back to what this really
means exactly in a minute.
So this is the k for
A plus B going to C.
And we think that
this is going to scale
with the number of A's and the
number of B's I've got, right?
And this depends on the
probability that I have A B C.
So if I'm in this state
with n A's n B's n C's--
that probability is
going to go down,
because the A's and B's can
react with each other, right?
Now on the other hand,
I have plus the same k.
And this is going to
be n A prime n B prime.
If I have some other state
that can react so that it makes
this state, then
I'll get a plus sign,
because probability of
this state would increase.
So for example, if n A prime
is equal to n A plus 1.
And n B prime is
equal to n B plus 1
and n C prime is
equal to n C minus 1,
then that state can react
by one of these A's and one
of these B's combining together
to make a C. That will get me
to this exact state here.
Does this make sense?
All Right, so that's
the master equation
if I have a system
that could only
do the irreversible reaction A
plus B goes to C. So the only--
I can go away-- because
the probability density
of this-- the probability
that this state can reduce,
because that reaction occurs
starting from this state.
And probability this
state can increase,
because I started from
this other state here--
this special state here.
And that would make
the state interest.
All right and so I have
equation-- this equation
over and over again, for every
possible value of n A, n B,
n C. Is this OK?
Now I have to actually--
remember for chemical
kinetics, that whenever
you have a forward reaction, you
also have the reverse reaction.
So there's actually
a couple more terms.
So now I have another loss term.
This is C goes to A plus B. This
is going to tell of the number
of C's.
And that's P of n
A n B n C. And then
I have another source term.
And this is where I start
from the state with one more
C. Is that OK?
So this set of equations is
called the kinetic master
equation.
And this is the equation that
describes the real system.
So this is the real probability
of finding the system with any
number of A's, B's, and C's.
And I have an equation like this
for every different possible
number of A's, number
of B's, number of C's.
All right?
And it's not bad as
an equation goes.
It's a linear
differential equation,
because it's linear
in P's, right?
There's just first--
everything's first power in P.
So in general, I can rewrite
this as dP dt is the some
matrix times B. And the matrix
entries are these prefactors--
things like this and this--
sorry, this, this.
These are the different
elements in the matrix, m.
So you should go ahead
and be able to write
any kinetic equation system--
rewrite it in this form
if you want.
It's called the kinetic
master equation.
Now if I do an
experiment like I talked
about with uranium, where I
put one uranium atom in there.
And all uranium
atoms can react to do
is fall apart to
lead plus neutrons,
or whatever the heck
they fall apart to.
So I can write down--
there's like one reaction
that uranium nuclei do.
And so I can write it out.
It will just be
something like this.
And this equation
will work for a case
where I put one uranium
atom in there to begin with.
I could do the case where I
put two uranium atoms in there
to begin with.
I could write this down.
Is that all right?
OK, now if I had a case where I
had 27 A's, 14 B's, and 33 C's
to start with, then you
can see that the number
of possibilities here
might get pretty large.
'Cause I have to consider,
well, I could lose one A,
and lose one B,
and get one more C.
But then I'll have an
equation for this term which
will look just like this.
But it'll go to ones where
I have lost two A's and two
B's and gained two C's.
And then all the way down, until
you get down to one of the n's
to be zero.
And so it could be quite a lot
of possible equations, right?
So the dimension-- the
length of the vector P
might get really long, right?
So the length of P is something
like the max number of A's, max
number of B's,
max number of C's.
All right, so if I have--
I'll allow-- consider systems
with up to 10 A's, 10 B's, 10
C's--
then this is 1,000--
P's a length of
approximately 1,000.
And it might be less than
that, because maybe there's
some of them-- some particular
states I can't get to.
So maybe it's less than 1,000,
but something like 1,000.
On the other hand, if
I allow it to a million
A's, a million B's, and
millions C's, then I,
like, 10 to the 18 length of P.
So P gets pretty long, pretty
fast when the number of
possible states goes up.
Is that all right?
So-- now, it's linear though.
And it's linear.
And this is constant
coefficients.
And so this is really
not-- and sparse.
So this is really--
it's not that bad.
And in fact Professor
Barton's group
has worked on these
kind of problems.
And he has to solves that can
work with P has dimension up
to 200 million.
So if you can keep the number--
say it's 200 million or less,
you can actually
solve this exactly.
Now solving this
exactly is really good,
because then you actually
have the exact probability
of any observable measurement
that you would possibly make
at any time, all computed, OK?
So that's really great.
But as I just pointed out,
if I make these numbers,
like, 10 to the 6, 10 to
the 6, and 10 to the 6--
this is like 10 of the 18.
That's a lot bigger
than 200 million.
And so Professor Barton's
numerical methods
are going to poop
out at some point,
and not going to
work for you anymore.
So there's a limited number
of problems you can do.
So if your problem small enough,
you can just solve this--
for really small ones you can
solve this with OD45 or OD15s
But because it's linear, there's
special solution methods.
I don't know if you remember
solutions of linear equations
this, you can relate
them to the eigenvectors
and eigenvalues of m.
And so you can do--
that's one way to do it.
And then there are special
methods you can do.
Talk to Professor Barton.
If it's sparse-- and it has
certain kinds properties,
you can make this really-- you
can make quite large systems,
up to 10 to the 8 kind of size.
If we get a system with more
than 10 to 8 possible states,
that means more than 10
to the 8 possible things
could be observed or
the result of experiment
could have more than
10 to 8 possibilities,
then this is-- you're
not going to be
able to solve it this way.
And so then we're
going to have to use
a stochastic solid solution
method to try to figure--
to do-- so we're going to
try a sample from P of t.
So I guess I should comment,
again, I wrote it this way.
But the thing--
P is definitely--
it depends on time.
So it's you'll have
different P for every time.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN: Yeah maybe
I'll just do better to--
I can substitute it in here.
Is that all right?
AUDIENCE: So, like, if you
transfer all the neighbors
in it, that's--?
WILLIAM GREEN: Yeah,
'cause a key idea
is that chemical kinetics
only does one step at a time.
So if you have a reaction
like this, at any instant
the probability
that two reactions
are going to be happening
exactly the same instant
is negligible.
So at any instant you're
only changing the numbers
of the atoms by one unit, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Then shouldn't
you add another A minus 1
and an E minus 1?
WILLIAM GREEN: Maybe
I got this backwards.
n A plus 1 plus 1 minus 1,
minus 1 minus 1 plus 1--
I think got-- I
think this is right.
So this is for the forward
reaction that always reduces
the number of A's and B's.
And this is the reverse reaction
that always increases them.
And so I think you
generally get like this.
You always get--
for any reaction,
you'll have four terms--
so the forward and
reverse, starting
from initial state, and
the forward and reverse
that make your state.
And then if you
add more reactions,
you have a system where you've
got a lot more reactions.
Maybe you have C's
that can just decompose
into B's or something--
different reactions.
Then you'd have a sum
like this with terms
like this from every reaction.
And you'd go through all your
list of all your reaction.
I guess there's one funny
thing I should point out
to you about this, which is
very important for this emulsion
polymerization case--
Is that if you have a reaction
of the type A plus A goes to--
I don't know-- B. That might
be a reaction you could have.
That when I write down
the equation, if I only
have one A in my sample, this
probability of this happening
is 0, right?
Because I need two A's
for this to happen.
So really, the equation for this
case is n A times n A minus 1.
So it's k A plus A goes to B
times n A times n A minus 1.
And this is crucial for, like,
the emulsion polymerization
case, 'cause the fact that I
don't have the second one is
really important.
Otherwise I always
miscompute that this radical
could react with
itself and terminate
itself, which is not true.
Is that all right?
I commented that these
k's are a little bit odd.
So if you remember, if you
have a k for a unimolecular
reaction, like C goes to A plus
B, what units would it have?
What are the units
for regular kinetics?
AUDIENCE: Inverse seconds.
WILLIAM GREEN: Right,
inverse seconds, right?
So you would normally
say this thing
has units of inverse seconds.
And that works fine here, right?
Because I have dP dt, and
it's in for a seconds times P,
so it's fine.
However, this guy-- to make
the units work out, still
has to also be inverse seconds,
but that's not normally
what you would have for
a bimolecular reaction.
And the other thing to watch
out for here is that I have n's.
But normally you would write
them with concentrations,
right?
You have the-- you'd
would write something
like k times the
concentration of C. It's
the normal way you write your
equations, the right equations.
But this is not the same, right?
This is n.
This is unitless.
Now it turns out, in
this case, actually, you
can use exactly the
same as k and it works.
But for the bimolecular case,
it definitely does not work.
The units are wrong.
And also this
concentration thing
implies that we think
the rate really has--
suppose we have k A k B. I
could rewrite this as k times n
A over the volume,
n B over the volume.
Is that all right?
Actually one thing I should
warn you about-- that
usually when I write this,
I write moles per liter.
So I have factors of 10 to
the 23 between this and this,
because these n's have got to
be the individual molecules
for this to work.
So watch out.
First of all, there's a 10
to the 23 somewhere in here,
right--
Avogadro's number.
And then this is what--
how we would normally write it.
But this k has the
wrong units for us here.
And so this guy here is the
normal k divided by the volume.
I think that's right.
Maybe it's the other way around.
No, this is normal
k times the volume.
That's right.
So normally we would
write units k normal--
normal kinetics, macro--
k for A plus B reactions,
the units are centimeters
cubed per mole second.
But we want them
to be units of--
the new k has got to
be units of per second.
And so the new k is equal to the
old k new old times the volume.
Is that right-- no
divided by the volume.
I was right the first time.
This is volume-- yeah.
Thank you-- centimetres
cubed, centimeters cubed--
yeah, right.
Cancelled out,
good for a second.
So this is k per volume normal
k divided by n-- correct.
And you may wonder,
well how come it's only
volume to the first power?
Before I had volume
to the second power
in the denominator.
And it's because I'm using
n's up in the numerator.
And it's just like here.
I'm using n's
instead of n over v.
So I've sort of multiplied
through by v everywhere.
That's one way to look at it.
All right, no questions yet?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So when
you [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN: Yeah, so I
need a 10 to the 23 as well.
So there's got to be
an Avogadro's number.
And you'll have to help me where
the Avogadro's number goes.
But it's got to be
in there somewhere,
to get from moles to molecules.
So the numbers are
a lot different.
Is this OK?
And this factor, this
n minus 1 thing--
again, when these are
macroscopic numbers like 10
to the 23, this makes
no difference, right?
Because it's minus 1.
So we can fit our
data ignoring the 1--
It's 1.
Perfectly well, the law of
mass action-- it works fine.
So you never notice
this unless you get
down to where n is very small.
But this is actually the truth.
This is really what the
correct equation is.
OK so now we have these--
the true equations
for predicting how the
probability distribution
evolves in a reacting system.
By the way, you can
add transport in
as well if you want.
So you have control
volumes, and you
know formulas for the rate at
which stuff is transported in
and out of the control volume.
You can add those
terms in as well.
And they'll affect the
probability distribution.
No problem, you should be able
to do the same conversion.
So just-- we've converted
the reaction equations.
You can write a similar thing.
Once you get right the
macroscopic transport equation,
you can figure out how
you would reduce it
down to a time
constant for transport
that would work for the--
for this microscopic
version of the equations.
So transport reaction-- you
can write the whole thing down
as a master equation.
That's a real solution,
the real equation.
And the problem is that the
real equation oftentimes
is too big, because P scales
up so rapidly with the number
of possible states.
So then we have to figure out
how are we going to solve it.
And the way to solve it is by--
called kinetic Monte Carlo.
And this method was invented
by a guy named Joe Gillespie.
And the journal paper is posted.
And this is just like
with Monte Carlo--
Metropolis Monte Carlo
that you just did.
We're trying to
find a way to sample
from the true
probability density
without ever computing the
true probability density.
So in the Monte
Carlo integration
you're doing for
homework, you're
sampling from the true
Boltzmann probability density,
but you never actually
supposedly write
down what that P is, right?
And so we're going to
do the same thing here,
is we're going to--
from the differential
equations--
from this differential
equation system
here, we're going to try to
somehow never ever solve this
directly, but instead just
sample from the solution, P,
which depends on time.
And the way it's
done is really to try
to follow individual
trajectories of what
could have happened, OK?
So at any time-step,
we have some number
of A's, B's and C's.
And we're going to say,
well in the next time
period, some small time
period, what could happen?
And we're going to make
the time period so small
that the only thing that can
happen is nothing happens,
and A, B and C stay
the same, or one event
happens which will change one
of the numbers, the A's, B's,
and C's, by the same
one reaction amount, OK?
And then after we accomplish
that, now we have a new state--
A, B, and C with
some new values.
And we'll do the
same thing again.
And we just repeat
that over and over.
So it's very brute force.
You're just doing, like, what
a single system would do.
So for example, for
the uranium atom case,
we have one uranium
atom in there.
We wait for some time
period, say 20 minutes.
We compute the probability
that the uranium would have
decayed in the last 20 minutes.
It's pretty small.
And then we'll say, OK, now
we'll draw a random number.
If the random number is
less than that probability,
then we think that the
uranium is still there.
And if the random number is
bigger than that probability,
then the uranium is gone.
If it's still there,
then we'll do it again.
And we'll just keep doing
that over and over again.
And we'll sample
what could happen.
The uranium atom could live
for 38 years and 14 minutes,
and then disappear.
And that would be one example.
And then we go back
and we do it again
from a different trajectory.
And we do it over and
over and over again.
And we do it over
and over again.
Those trajectories are sampling
from what could happen,
with the right
probability density.
Does this make sense?
So the way Gillespie
says to do it
is figure out the expected time
until something would happen.
We'll call this time tau.
And we'll pull-- actually
let's not use tau,
because that's the
only one that--
I'll try to be consistent
with Joe's notation.
He calls this thing 1/a.
So a is like the
expected rate per second.
And 1/a is the expected time
until something would happen.
And then we'll draw
a random number r--
he calls it r1.
So we just call
the rand function.
It gives me a number
between 0 and 1.
And I'll say that my
time-step, delta t--
which Joe calls tau, is
1/a the logarithm of 1/o.
So I think there should
be a negative sign.
No, 1/r is positive.
That's right-- positive.
All right, so I choose
a random number.
Suppose it's 1/2.
Then this fraction is 2--
1 over 1/2 is 2.
Logarithm of 2 is some
number bigger than 1.
And I pull that.
And I get some--
actually, some number less
than 1-- logarithm of 2--
anyway, some positive number.
Multiply it by the expected
time until something happens--
and that's the time, in
this particular simulation,
when the next thing happened.
And then I repeat this
again, and again, and again.
And I get the period of
time intervals between when
something happened.
Now every time something
happened, I have to figure out,
well, what happened?
So if I look at my--
plot back here when I had the
uranium, I waited a long--
in this particular
case, here's my tau.
I'll call this tau 1--
the time that it took for
the first thing to happen.
And then, well--
what could happen?
The only thing can happen with
my single uranium atom case
is it decayed.
So it went away.
All right, and then I do
the random thing again.
And I draw.
And I get a different
number this time.
How long it is 'till
something happened.
Now notice-- maybe
it's not so obvious--
that in the time until something
happens changes as you run.
So for example, if I started
out with 100 uranium atoms
in 100 little boxes.
And I'm watching them.
After I've run this
for a long time,
I only have 50
uranium atoms left.
And that means that
the average time
period until something
happens will be slower,
because I don't have as many.
The more I have, the more
rapidly something will happen.
Does that make sense?
So I have to compute this
a thing at each iteration.
So I compute the time
until something happens.
Then I'm going to
compute what happened.
I'll tell you what
that the second.
In the uranium case, the
only thing that can happen
is one of the uranium
atoms decayed.
So I took that away.
Now I have to compute a again.
So a is the sum of all the
things that can happen.
So in my case where I
have 100 uranium atoms,
I have 100 different boxes.
In each one of them, there is
a rate at which uranium atom
probability is decaying.
It's like 1 over the normal
half life uranium-- or something
like that.
And I add them up.
So a is the sum of the rates
of everything that can happen.
So we just list out all
the different things
that can happen.
So in the case-- suppose
I have two boxes--
two uranium atoms.
I can have decay of uranium
atom number one or uranium atom
number two.
So I have-- this thing
would be equal to--
so two uranium atoms--
a is equal to 1 over tau normal
for a uranium atom plus one
over tau normal.
Because they're both
normal uranium atoms.
So it's equal to 2/tau.
And so 1/a is half of
the normal lifetime.
And that's when I would
expect that something
would happen by then, OK?
One of them would
probably decay.
So that would be the a
value I would use here.
Draw my random
number, get my tau
until something
probably happened,
then figure out what happens.
Now in the kinetics case,
several different things
can happen, right?
I wrote down if I'm in
state n A n B n C, I--
the state can change
by two different ways.
I can move out of that
state this way or this way.
Two different
reactions can happen--
a forward or reverse reaction.
And they would both take
me out of the state.
So those are two different
things that can happen.
And so I have to
add those rates.
So I would add this
number and this number.
And they would be the two
things that could happen.
And that would give
me the a value.
Now I figured out
something happened.
But now I'm not doing uranium.
Now doing, say, number of A's.
Now I figured out
something happened.
But now I have to figure
out what happened.
And the number of A's could
have gone up or gone down,
because if it was
a forward reaction,
the number of A's went down.
If it was a reverse reaction,
the number of A's went up.
So I have to decide which
way is going to happen.
So I could have either the
number of A's went down,
or the number of A's went up.
Those are two possibilities.
I have to figure out
which one happened.
I have to figure--
draw another random
number to figure out
which one probably happened.
So I'll list out the list
of all the things that
can happen with their rates.
And one of them, say, is
twice as big as the other.
So that'll be twice
as likely to happen.
So I have to choose
a random number,
and use that to
choose the next one.
So first I figured out--
this is actually
what we did first.
I figured out what my rates are.
Second thing is I figure out the
time until something happened.
Third thing is I'm going to
figure out what happened.
And what I do is I say--
I draw a random
number called r2.
And if there's only
two possibilities
like in this case,
then I can say
if r2 is less than the
rate of process one divided
by the sum of the rates, which
is the same as the a, right?
So this is-- it this is true,
then process one happened.
On the other hand, if the rate--
if the random number I chose
is larger than this ratio, then
I'll say process two happened.
And that's how I decide whether
a number of A's went up or went
down.
And then I would recompute the
a-- depending on what happened.
Suppose I do this.
And I found out that the
number of A's went up--
because I-- by drawing
the random number.
Then I'll go and I'll
recompute the A. Now
the rates will all be different,
because n A is bigger.
So the rate of the n
A reaction is faster.
So I recompute it.
I redraw a number here, and
get some different time, tau 2.
It's not the same as tau 1.
And then something
happened here.
I do the same process
here out what happened.
Maybe this time A reacted
away and it went back down.
And then I do it again.
And this time I draw
a longer time, tau 3.
And I do-- what happened?
And maybe this time, again,
something reacted away.
And it went down.
And on, and on, and on--
and after my computer is
done doing that for a while,
like, after a long enough
time, I say, OK, I'm done.
Oh-- I'm not really done.
I have to go back
and start it again,
and run another
simulation to run
through all the possibilities.
And I want to save all
these results of all
these simulations,
because these guys are
samples from the
probability distribution.
And if I built histograms
of stuff from those guys
I can figure out what
really is going to happen.
All right, so it's a way to
represent the P. Questions?
All right-- perfectly clear?
All right, so what's nice
about this is actually,
it's not that hard
once you do this once.
It's not hard to do it.
And you can do it for
any problem at all.
And so it's like--
often cases people do
this even for cases
where you actually could solve--
you might be able to
solve this equation.
A lot times, people won't do it.
They'll do this instead
just because it's so easy.
So though maybe it looks
hard to you right now,
it's only a three step thing.
And just do it over,
and over again.
You're not doing it.
The computer's doing it--
no big deal.
And so this one
you have to, like,
look at the sparsity
pattern of your m--
and some complicated stuff.
So this is actually
done extremely commonly.
All right, see you on Friday.